[Música]
según reporta el ministerio de gobierno
de haití están bajo custodia de la
policía nacional los presuntos asesinos
del presidente y tiene el joven el mois
quien murió a manos de un grupo de
hombres armados que ingresaron en su
residencia a la crisis política actual
de ese país se suma ahora una crisis de
sucesión en el poder analizamos el tema
en minutos
los rescatistas desplegados en el lugar
del colapso del edificio en el short
site en florida descartaron encontrar
sobrevivientes después de dos semanas de
búsqueda y de rescate a partir de la
medianoche de hoy el operativo se
concentrará en recuperar los cuerpos
bajo los escombros hasta el momento 54
muertos han sido confirmados
y en nuestra serie de reportajes
especiales sobre la vida después de
padecer y recuperarse del hobby 19 les
tenemos la historia de catherine logo
una mujer que nos recuerda el compromiso
social y la importancia de la labor de
las cuidadoras a domicilio en tiempos de
pandemia les contamos la historia
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por acompañarnos a esta
hora vamos a comenzar en haití en donde
hay novedades en torno al asesinato del
presidente joven l moix según lo que
reporta en este momento el ministerio de
gobierno de ese país caribeño ya están
bajo custodia los presuntos asesinos del
presidente moix recordemos que el
mandatario haitiano murió a manos de un
grupo de hombres armados que ingresó en
su residencia en horas de la madrugada
varios líderes de américa latina y
también del mundo así como varios
organismos internacionales han mostrado
su rechazo al asesinato del presidente
en la madrugada de hoy como les decíamos
ocurrió este hecho en la ciudad de
puerto príncipe y así lo reportaba en
los medios internacionales a la ya
complicada crisis sanitaria y política
que atraviesa el país caribeño se suma
ahora el hecho sin precedentes del
asesinato del presidente que ha
comenzado a crear una gran confusión
sobre quién sigue en la línea de
sucesión dado que la constitución
haitiana no es clara al respecto y
muchos de los cargos que hacen parte de
la estructura del
se encuentran vacantes de manera
interina el primer ministro del país
cloud
josep asumió las riendas de este país y
declaró el estado de sitio vamos a
analizar este tema saludamos a jonas
duma él es licenciado en trabajo social
también es máster en políticas sociales
es ciudadano haitiano se encuentra en la
ciudad de posadas en la provincia de
misiones en argentina muy buenas noches
señor del mar gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 y dimensionemos la
magnitud de este hecho la muerte del
presidente en medio de esta crisis
políticas y sanz también sanitaria e
institucional que significa para haití
el asesinato del presidente joven el
mois
buenas tardes santiago y buenas tardes a
los televidentes
la muerte del presidente llega en un
momento donde la situación política
económica del país ya estaba en un caos
y la situación actual del país con la
muerte del presidente nos lleva
directamente al catástrofe a una
tragedia nosotros o sea nadie sabe qué
va a pasar porque en haití hay muchos
grupos armados algunos responden al
poder y otros responden a sectores
opositores es decir hay muchas
condiciones reunidas para que el país
caiga en un cabo total en una guerra
civil o sea ya habían grupos armados
peleando en distintos barrios populares
también el país ha sufrido varias
masacres en distintos barrios populares
el territorio de la capital sobre todo
no está controlado por el gobierno de
haití por tanto en ese vacío
institucional que ya estaba
existente antes de la muerte del
presidente llegamos en una situación
como no sabemos cuál es la salida señor
tumbar la sucesión del poder hay en
haití
es clara ya lo decíamos la constitución
no especifica exactamente cómo debe ser
este proceso entonces qué va a pasar en
el contexto actual que tiene el país
bueno en realidad no es que la
constitución
no está clara sino que hay dos
constituciones hay una condición del
que dice que en caso de ausencia del
presidente debería asumir el el juez de
la corte suprema y hay una constitución
revisada en el año 2012 que dice que
este cargo lo debería asumir el primer
ministro sin embargo esta constitución
revisada de dormir 2012 no tiene
consenso en la clase política fue
rechazada porque decían algunos sectores
políticas no estaba sancionada en los
dos idiomas oficiales del país y además
fue aplicada fue adoptada digamos sobre
el gobierno de michel martelly y el
gobierno anterior al yo ver maurice que
en muchos sectores de la sociedad
consideran que no tenía legitimidad
esta esta constitución por tanto hoy el
más cerca del poder sería el primer
ministro actual sí que es el encargado
de llevar a este país a las elecciones
presidenciales de febrero señores duma
muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 hacer este análisis para
nuestra audiencia cambiamos de tema no
hay posibilidad de encontrar
sobrevivientes bajo los escombros del
edificio residencial que colapsó en la
zona de surfside en el estado de florida
en el sur de eeuu así lo indicaron los
oficiales del cuerpo de bomberos del
condado de miami dade tras dos semanas
de un intenso operativo de búsqueda de
rescate que ahora dará paso a un
operativo de recuperación de víctimas el
cambio en este tipo de operativo se dará
a partir de la medianoche de este
miércoles el número de muertos
confirmados aumentó ya a 54 tras el
hallazgo de otros ocho cuerpos en la
jornada de hoy sin embargo los
rescatistas continúan tras la pista de
más de 80 personas que siguen bajo los
escombros
y después
con profunda tristeza les comparto que
tomamos la extremadamente difícil
decisión de hacer la transición de la
operación de búsqueda y rescate a la
operación de recuperaciones en
sí
han pasado exactamente dos semanas desde
que la torre sur de champaign se
derrumbó y durante los últimos 14 días
como saben todos ustedes nuestros
equipos de búsqueda y rescate locales de
florida de todo el país y de hecho del
mundo entero han estado buscando entre
los escombros han usado todas las
estrategias posibles y todas las
herramientas de tecnología a su alcance
la idea de la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos recomendó al gobierno
colombiano separar la policía y su
escuadrón móvil antidisturbios conocido
como smart de la órbita del ministerio
de defensa esto tras constatar el uso
excesivo de la fuerza por parte de
integrantes de estas instituciones
durante las recientes movilizaciones
ciudadanas que comenzaron el pasado mes
de abril la comisión recomendó esta
separación para garantizar una
estructura que consolide y que también
preserven la seguridad de los ciudadanos
colombianos y garantice los derechos
humanos también abogó por que no sean
prohibidos los bloqueos de manera
generalizada el gobierno del presidente
iván duque rechazó este informe y por
supuesto rechazó también las
recomendaciones hechas por este
organismo
[Música]
y a lo largo de la semana les hemos
presentado nuestros reportajes
especiales de quienes han padecido el
hobby 19 se han recuperado y hoy en día
cuentan su historia en esta oportunidad
conoceremos la historia de catherine
logo quien nos recuerda la importancia
de la labor de las cuidadoras a
domicilio en tiempos de pandemia hasta
su historia
en junio de 2020 vino a defender la
causa de las cuidadoras a domicilio un
año después
catherine long sigue movilizada para las
personas mayores
en este pueblo 17 personas murieron de
covite remy logró recuperarse después de
enfermar en marzo de 2020
afortunadamente no desarrolló una forma
muy grave de covite en comparación con
migo
pero bueno está bien estoy en marzo de
2020 sin acceso a tapabocas katrin
contrajo el virus y lo transmitió a su
marido que pasó 12 días hospitalizado
retomó el trabajo pero sigue sin poder
organizar comidas o salidas en grupo
algo que raquel de 97 años la menta
tenemos suerte de tenerlas si no fuera
por ellas qué haríamos estaría en una
residencia y yo no tengo ganas de ir a
una residencia
quizás llegará el día en que será
necesario pero espero que sea lo más
tarde posible 27 horas a la semana
pagadas con el salario mínimo
condiciones que no han cambiado por la
pandemia
no tenemos ningún reconocimiento tampoco
salarial
el gobierno promete un aumento de sueldo
en octubre mientras tanto katrin y sus
compañeras esperan que la crisis
sanitaria haya ayudado a visibilizar y a
reconocer su profesión historia de vida
en tiempos de pandemias todo por el
momento aquí en france24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]